le Golfe du Morbihan est un écosystème
fragile
[Musique]
l'équilibre n'y tient parfois qu'à un
fil et les habitants de Belle-Île le
savent bien tous se souviennent de
l'année 1999 et du naufrage de l'irika
aujourd'hui
les deux demoiselles de 80 nous sommes
le 11 décembre 1999 depuis plusieurs
jours une forte dépression s'est abattue
sur l'Atlantique Nord là où il était
énorme avec des creux de 8 mètres
l'Erika un pétrolier de 180 mètres de
long fait face à des conditions de
navigation difficiles à l'entrée du golf
de Gascogne
le vieux pétrolier flottant pavillon
maltais a quitté Dunkerque quelques
jours auparavant avec 30 000 tonnes de
full lourd destiné au port de Livourne
en Italie
mais dans la nuit du 11 au 12 décembre
alors que la tempête fait rage des
fissures dans la coque de l'Erika
apparaissent et s'agrandissent
dangereusement au fil des heures le
pétrolier prend de la gîte et devient
hors de contrôle
à 6h du matin le commandant lance un
appel de détresse il donne sa position
environ 100 km à l'ouest de Belle-Île et
demande l'évacuation de son équipage
la préfecture maritime de Brest ordonne
alors à l'abeille Flandres d'appareil le
puissant remorqueur doit se rendre le
plus vite possible sur la zone du
naufrage
[Musique]
à bord se trouve un journaliste et
écrivain de Marie
Hervé Hamon connait bien l'univers des
tempêtes
depuis quelques mois lorsque le mauvais
temps s'annonce il embarque sur
l'abeille avec son carnet et une petite
caméra
il veut raconter l'émission méconnue de
ses sauveteurs hors normes
il n'oubliera jamais ce voyage
ça pétait vraiment très très fort et
surtout on devait faire route au maximum
de vitesse possible contre le vent et
contre le courant
la caractéristique de ce genre de bateau
c'est que c'est un bateau tout temps
c'est à dire que c'est un bateau qui
peut aller le plus vite possible dans
n'importe quel temps
quand on a passé le ras de ça je me
rappelle très bien j'ai jamais vu la
vieille comme ça quoi c'était c'était
vraiment le phare était complètement
entouré des cums en le voyait plus je
pense qu'on a mis à peu près trois
heures à arriver sur zone c'est assez
loin et bien avant d'arriver à
l'hérica même je dirais même avant de le
voir on a vu une traînée sur la mer qui
était qui était le pétrole quoi
le remorqueur de haute mer poursuit donc
sa route plein sud il est 9 heures du
matin
au même moment à Vannes dans le Morbihan
deux hommes s'apprêtent à décoller pour
photographier la tempête
juste avant leur départ ils apprennent
ce qui est en train de se passer au
large
quand le gars du sémaphore à qui on
demande si c'est beau nous dit oui mais
en plus de ça si vous voulez
photographier un bateau qui coule il y
en a un qui est en train de couler quoi
c'est évident que on saute dessus quoi
c'est évident on s'est regardé tous les
deux on s'est tout de suite compris on a
sorti l'hélico du hangar il avait le il
avait le point GPS et puis droit dessus
le photographe Yannick Le Gall et le
pilote Daniel manory ne le savent pas
encore mais ils vont vivre l'un des
moments les plus marquants de leur
carrière
au large l'Erika est désormais cassé en
deux
sa coque avance s'enfonce dans l'océan
et relâche une partie de sa cargaison
un peu plus loin à la dérive la partie
arrière du pétrolier flotte encore avec
dans ses cuves des milliers de tonnes de
fioul
arrivé sur zone les hélicoptères de la
marine réussissent l'exploit d'évacuer
les 26 membres d'équipage durant plus de
deux heures ils élittruent les marins
qui ont trouvé refuge sur de petites
chaloupes de sauvetage
je me souviens moi de très très loin
c'était de petites têtes d'épingles qui
nous ont permis de les repérer et après
on était seul seul avec le navire cassé
en deux
mes premières sensations ça a été de me
dire
c'est de la belle lumière puis j'ai pu
raisonner comme ça parce que justement
il n'y avait pas visiblement une
catastrophe humaine humaine dans le sens
où il y avait pas des hommes à la mer ou
là j'aurais évidemment pas raisonné de
la même manière
attention son cadrage la lumière la
couleur qui était du bon côté l'écume
qui qui déferlaient sur le côté et le
don de l'Erika qui était important pour
nous pour l'image on faisait une image
quoi c'est ça
moi j'ai trouvé que l'avant de l'Erika
c'était ce qu'ils étaient de le plus
impressionnant moi ça m'a fait penser à
un rorqual qui sort de l'eau
une énorme baleine ou bah oui on est
devant quelque chose d'inédique quelque
chose de fort quelque chose de tout en
réalisant que ça allait être une aussi
une catastrophe naturelle quoi
on avait un peu d'expérience des vents
des courants de la situation
géographique on savait que ça allait que
ça allait être monstrueux sur sur les
îles c'était une évidence
le naufrage du pétrolier l'Erika au
large de Brest le navire qui battait
pavillon maltais s'est brisé en deux
dans la tempête les 26 hommes d'équipage
ont pu être secourus mais l'inquiétude
vient ce soir des 24000 mètres cubes de
fioul lourd qui se sont répandus dans la
mer les nappes qui s'est formée dérives
actuellement vers le large il n'y aurait
aucun risque de pollution côtière selon
le cèdre le centre de recherche
Marie Thuillier collégienne à l'époque
et comme la plupart des habitants elle
est accrochée aux dernières nouvelles
comprenez pas trop parce
Thibault grand le monde est lui aussi
très inquiet en décembre 1999 il vit
avec ses parents dans un petit village
de la côte ouest
c'est l'un des endroits les plus
sauvages de Belle-Île
quand le bateau s'est cassé en deux là
déjà on a tous été secoué c'est devenu
le sujet de conversation principale sur
l'île mais c'est une catastrophe elle va
arriver la catastrophe ou quand on sait
pas
dimanche 12 décembre il est 14h dans la
passerelle de l'abeille Flandres Hervé
Hamon est toujours derrière sa petite
caméra
l'équipage vient d'arriver sur la zone
du naufrage et cherche un moyen de
remorquer le pétrolier
c'est le début d'une mission périlleuse
quand on est arrivé on a vu pierrica
c'était complètement cassé en deux
l'avant envoyé plus que le bulbe qui
dépassait dans une mare de pétrole en
revanche la partie arrière flottait
encore bien et était elle était un peu
levée comme ça elle était à peu près
comme ça mais on voyait quand même que
cette partie arrière tenait le coup et
donc on se disait que la moitié du
pétrole était encore dedans et on avait
remarqué qu'à l'arrière du bateau il y
avait une remorque
donc les gars ont bien regardé et il y
en a deux qu'on dit ouais je pense qu'on
peut le faire et je suis volontaire pour
y aller
on savait que le bateau est en train de
dériver droit sur Lille et que si on
intervenait pas si on n'arrive pas au
moins à le stopper il allait se crasher
sur l'île et saloper tout le coin
Charles Claudel le commandant du
remorqueur coordonne les opérations avec
les hélicoptères
deux marins de l'abeille sont déposés
sur le pont arrière de l'Erika qui gîte
fortement
ils doivent absolument trouver un moyen
d'accrocher le câble de remorquage
car les Rica menacent de couler à tout
instant
[Musique]
Charles avait demandé que l'hélico reste
vraiment aussi précisément que possible
au dessus de façon à les récupérer à la
volée le plus vite possible c'était
quand même très chaud là on a peur on a
peur collectivement les gars ils ont
peur aussi
et moi j'aimais bien cet esprit d'équipe
chacun à sa place et toujours quelqu'un
couvre en l'autre
chaque matelot se positionner suivant ce
que lui demandait le bosco et puis tout
le monde travaillait sous la protection
de l'autre
dans cette mer formée les manœuvres sont
délicates il faut jouer sans cesse sur
la tension de l'énorme câble pour ne pas
qu'il se brise
avec toute sa puissance l'abeille
Flandres va tenter de remorquer vers le
large ce qui reste de l'Erika
faut à tout prix que le navire et sa
cargaison ne coule pas près des côtes
françaises
au bout d'un moment là vraiment
rapidement je pourrais trois quarts
d'heure une heure on a compris une chose
c'est que on pouvait pas bouger si on
arrivait à la tenir sur zone sans
qu'elle dérive sans que le camp à
la côte ça serait déjà pas mal
toute la nuit du 13 au 14 décembre les
sauveteurs font ce qu'ils peuvent pour
éviter le pire
mais le lendemain matin la partie
arrière de l'Erika s'enfonce
inexorablement vers les profondeurs
je vois l'agonie du bateau c'est à dire
que
l'eau était en train d'entrer la cloison
est en train de lâcher et donc
l'arrière du bateau c'est dressé
progressivement ça a pris un certain
temps 40 minutes quelque chose comme ça
et puis le bateau s'est engagé
je pense que pour n'importe quel marin
ça c'est un drôle de truc c'est un drôle
de moment il y a un moment de silence
quand il y a un bateau qui coule c'est
une mort c'est une mort
oui est-elle de l'Abeille Flandre sera
clair nous recevez-vous oui je vous
donne la position exacte de 47 degrés 9
minutes 24 points 5 secondes Nord
[Musique]
des puits de la nuit de Noël elle se
sont déposées sur les plages du
Finistère du Morbihan à Belle-Île et
jusqu'en Loire-Atlantique et la hotte
est encore pleine cette pollution va
s'étendre sur des semaines voire des
mois le 25 décembre au matin les rivages
de Belle-Île sont envahis par une marée
noire qui empoisonne tout sur son
passage
une dizaine d'oiseaux malades du pétrole
au début on n'y croit pas on se dit bon
on verra demain et le matin je me suis
réveillé j'ai pris mon vélo je suis venu
ici parce qu'ici Porcel pour moi c'est
mon quartier c'est c'est là où j'ai
grandi et avant d'arriver en haut de la
côte là-bas j'ai senti l'odeur et là tu
te dis
il y a quelque chose il y a quelque
chose mais tu crois toujours pas jusqu'à
jusqu'à arriver ici et découvrir
l'ampleur des dégâts
pendant des semaines poussées par les
vents et les courants les nappes de
fioul qui s'échappent encore de l'épave
viennent s'échouer du littoral breton
jusqu'à la Vendée
[Musique]
il y a plus de mer c'était que c'était
une mère de pétrole d'une mère de
pétrole épais c'était marron c'était
visqueux il y en avait déjà partout
c'était remonté sur les rochers les
rochers terres couverts comme d'un gros
caramel visqueux épais et puis c'est moi
ce qui m'a le plus frappé c'est c'est
qu'on voyait la mer passé sous le
pétrole qui était venu se poser sur
toute cette plage puis le pétrole
bougeait tout doucement avec le avec les
mouvements des vagues successifs qui
arrivaient on a l'impression que le
paradis dans lequel on a vécu est
terminé et puis que jamais jamais ça
reviendra comme c'était avant quoi
la pimprenelle qui est là passionné de
botanique Yves briin guide aujourd'hui
les visiteurs le long des falaises qui
bordent les plus belles criques de son
île
la à l'époque du naufrage il était maire
du palais et donc en première ligne pour
tenter de sauvegarder le littoral
ton couvercle
assez allez presque 10 mètres au-dessus
des pleines de mer de Vivaux quand même
oui jusqu'où jusqu'où la mer peut faire
Shrek et le pétrole alors il devait être
mou à l'époque oui il s'est collé là
maintenant il est devenu dur
les gens ils ont pris n'importe quoi ils
sont allés à la côte groupés
seuls à quelques-uns et ils ont commencé
à ramasser du pétrole et puis des sans
savoir trop le mettre tu vois on le
collait en arrière on faisait des trous
et c'est vrai que les 15 premiers jours
avant que tout s'organise sous les sous
l'égides alors d'une part des élus de
l'île et puis des pouvoirs publics c'est
un espèce de mouvement brownien quoi les
gens se précipitent on essaye d'enlever
le pétrole comme si par miracle on
allait pouvoir le faire alors que tous
les jours il en arrive autant quoi mais
c'est une réaction on nettoie on veut
nettoyer tout ça parce que c'est
insupportable c'est insupportable
il y a eu les premières heures ça a été
il y a une espèce de vide de désarroi
complet et puis chacun s'est mis à aller
chercher des stocks de gants des sauts
des bâches et puis on a on a commencé
petit à petit comme ça à ramasser chacun
avec nos petits moyens et comme ici moi
j'étais à la crique qui est juste
derrière après on avait organisé un
petit groupe et puis on avait fait une
toute petite chaîne avec les outils de
chantier de mon père et puis et puis on
ramassait quoi
les oiseaux marins qui vivaient se
nourrissent en haute mer sont les
premières victimes de la cargaison
toxique de l'Erika
englué et incapable de voler ils ont
dérivé à la côte avant les premières
nappes de fioul
malgré leur maigre connaissance en
matière d’ornithologie finalement
à se porter au secours de ses oiseaux
c'était ici l'endroit où on ramassait
les oiseaux pour la première fois
et c'est dans les mêmes contextes avec
des grosses vagues comme ça pareil
quand il y avait le mazout mais il y
avait même pas de petits éclats il y
avait de mer ou quoi que ce soit c'était
c'était plat c'était c'était mort il y
avait pas de bruit il y avait rien quoi
c'était
[Musique]
c'était pas beau à voir
il y avait une vague un oiseau
ça c'est les petits guimau qui sont
arrivés échoués sur la plage avec tous
les galettes là qu'on voit et puis qui
s'était complètement englué
une fois qu'ils étaient après mis dans
des dans des lavabos avec des jets d'une
certaine température avec un shampoing
spécialement pour ça pour essayer
d'enlever le maximum de et tout ça à la
brosse à dents pour essayer de nettoyer
de plumes par plumes une piscine avait
été installée pour que les oiseaux
puissent se baigner dedans pour qu'ils
puissent imperméabiliser leur plumes et
puis si on voyait que l'oiseau coulait
c'est qu'il était encore mal nettoyé et
puis qu'il fallait recommencer en fait
jusqu'à ce que le l'oiseau flotte
c'était dur de voir ça parce que bon
même pour la bête et c'est pour ça que
des fois il y en a qui stressaient et
puis qui n'y arrivait pas de toute façon
à survivre
[Musique]
un mois après le naufrage le photographe
Yannick Le Gall est de retour à
Belle-Île
il veut immortaliser les opérations de
nettoyage
la deuxième sortie que je crois qu'elle
devait être le 19 avec Daniel on avait
fait Belle-Ile on était allé sur la côte
du Croisic là c'est beaucoup plus la
consternation quoi on est plus dans la
même logique là on voit le résultat de
la catastrophe
non là envoyer c'était un travail de
fourmi ouais c'était une toute autre
ambiance on était moins dans le
spectaculaire mais on était plus dans le
dramatique quelque part
ils sont bénévoles pompiers ou
militaires venu des quatre coins de
France pour aider les Bélinois pendant
des semaines ils vont nettoyer les
outrages du pétrolier maltais
par centaines il se relaient sur les
falaises au fond des criques et sur les
plages
on tente aussi de piéger le pétrole en
mer avant qu'il ne touche la côte
sauvage
c'est une véritable bataille contre la
marée noire que décrit chaque jour
Jacquie Lemaire dans un petit carnet
c'est l'impression que ça va donner
c'est un récit de guerre parce que il y
a eu des stratégies à développer il y a
eu du matériel on dira des armes pour
lutter parce que nous n'avions
strictement rien du tout
[Musique]
nous sommes aux aiguilles de port-cotton
à cet acide emblématique de l'île dans
des endroits comme ça difficile d'accès
nous avons eu recours grâce aux
montagnards qui nous sont venus nous
aider à des tyroliennes qui partaient et
qui partaient du niveau de la mer
jusqu'au haut de la côte pour
transporter jusqu'à une tonne de Big Bag
avec de la merde à la fois
ça a quand même duré un peu plus d'un an
s'il y a eu quelques moments de
découragement mais en pleine perceptique
parce que il fallait à tout prix qu'on
nettoie
au cœur de cette lutte interminable un
autre forçat du mazout ne compte plus
ses efforts pierre Mouti et le seul à
avoir conservé un échantillon de la
cargaison
voilà le pétrole de l'héritage
il en reste
on a tendance à oublier toujours
une fois que c'est nettoyé on voit plus
mais c'est ça qu'on avait ramassé
il y en avait des fois jusqu'à 20 cm
d'épaisseur quand on a enlevait ça des
rochers tout venait avec les berniques
les algues tout venaient avec et plus
rien en dessous
le pétrole c'est quand même quelque
chose à la base qui est naturel je dis
pas que ça se dégrade facilement mais ça
finit par se dégrader tout de même après
quand il y en a trop il y en a trop
ça se dégrade plus ou pas au même rythme
c'est beaucoup plus long à guérir on va
dire après c'est la dose qui fait le
poison quand on voit ce qu'on a enlevé
si on avait attendu que la marée fasse
le travail ce sera encore bien pourri
comme il faut
l'enquête sur ce naufrage désastreux
révélera plus tard que cette fortune de
mer est liée à une importante corrosion
de la coque de l'Erika et un très
mauvais entretien du pétrolier
pourquoi il y a des marées noires il y a
des marées noires parce que il y a une
chaîne de responsable et dans cette
chaîne de responsable si un ou deux
se mettent à déconner
se mettre à prendre le risque que
quelque chose puisse déraper au total à
l'arrivée on va avoir le pépin le gros
pépin
et photos de manif est-ce que tu te
rappelles des chansons qu'on avait écrit
sur le bateau
et on a vantaux démarré où es-tu que
fais-tu et je passe la suite parce que
ça dégénère
au début on était vraiment dans la dans
la tristesse l'incompréhension mais là
on était dans la colère
on espère toujours que la génération qui
suive va être mieux que nous qui elles
se sentira plus concernés par les
questions environnementales notamment
celle-là donc peut-être qu'un jour ils
seront suffisamment forts pour un poids
sur le législateur parce que on a
l'impression finalement que il y a des
effets ou on se dit plus jamais ça comme
on le voyait sur nos banderoles quand on
allait à Nantes on veut plus jamais ça
mais qu'est-ce qui a été mis en place
demain pour que des bateaux poubelles se
casse pas certaines choses oui mais ça
va sans doute pas assez loin
la moko il y a 40 ans les Rica là il y a
20 ans on se dit ben est-ce que ça va
recommencer un jour donc l'inquiétude
une fois qu'on a connu ça le demeure
la nature paraît avoir une bonne
résilience c'est le cas mais il y a
quand même des domaines de la nature qui
n'ont pas autant de résilience en
Bretagne par exemple aujourd'hui les
alcides c'est bien les petits pingouins
et les guimaux les macareux ils sont au
bord de la disparition
Belly l'a retrouvé son visage d'origine
on a pu cette odeur on a pu tout ça mais
on n'est jamais à l'abri de rien mais
jamais à l'abri parce que quand on voit
tous les gros bateaux qui passent au
large même si il y a plus de contrôle
plus de sécurité mais on n'est jamais à
l'abri de rien
les habitants de Belle-Île-en-Mer ont
depuis longtemps retrouvé le paradis
sauvage perdu un jour de descendre
les cicatrices ne sont plus visibles
mais la fragilité de cet écosystème
demeure et mérite toute notre attention
et notre respect
[Musique]